by everyone we'd like to invite you to
the official opening celebration of the
regular woody in Perth that's this
Saturday at 9:30 rain or shine
we're on the corner of Kippenberger and
Devlin herbs and we'll be holding the
opening in this grass area just behind
me there'll be a coffee cart spot prizes
and a prize draw so bring your sneakers
and your bike and we'll see you there
it's here the official opening of the
regular wooden path is Saturday 23rd of
June will be given away to $500 bike
vouchers plus spot prizes and coffee
vendor strip on your walking shoes bring
your bike and give it a try 9:30 a.m.
set day 23rd to June corner of Kevin
burger and Devlin Avenue